all right one local credit union is here
to help both the community
and credit especially as online and on
mobile banking become more and more
relied on take a look
scott welcome to las vegas now thank you
rocky glad to be here
you are the president and ceo of let me
get this right
silver state schools credit union yes
that's correct
and of course during coven 19 um a lot
of people are relying heavily on
online baking so how are you guys
helping people with that
yeah of course so silver state schools
credit union has really prioritized our
online and mobile banking
options especially during the pandemic
our members can securely access their
accounts anytime
anyplace and members are able to monitor
transactions
uh uh check their balances transfer
funds manage bill pay
even apply for a loan believe it or not
through mobile banking so we also offer
secure chat
where members can chat with a live
member service rep through their mobile
apps can you tell us more about those
financial security services
yeah yep so um you know one of the
things that we thought was really really
important rocky was to in early october
we decided to launch
a revolutionary app called card force
and i
always like to say that sounds like
something from star wars or something
like that
but card force gives our members control
over their
silver state schools credit union debit
and or credit cards
and through the app you can actually
receive real-time alerts
when your card's used and set
transaction limits and most importantly
turn your cards on or off if it's ever
lost stolen or misplaced which
i don't if you've ever lost your your
card that's a pretty big thing and so
you actually go online and and it's just
a flip of the switch on your mobile app
of course you guys obviously are doing
so much for the community what does it
mean to you
as a company to be a community partner
yep
well as credit unions we're member owned
and so that's it's really important for
us to give back to our members
and to the community that's really
helped us grow over the soon to be 70
years well
in january we're actually celebrating
our 70th year uh
in in business so and yeah so various
ways that we do that is to partner with
organizations in the community like
clark county school district
unlv on anson's piggy bank program
and even the vegas golden knights and
i wanted to point out in march of this
year the board of directors and
the executive team of silver state
schools credit union actually decided to
make a 150
000 donation to uh ccsu
i'm sorry clark county school district
um to specifically purchase
approximately 1500 chromebooks uh for
students to help bridge the virtual
learning needs for students um and ccsd
during the pandemic
and how do people become members of the
union yep so
it's very easy so whether you're a
volunteer student
um retiree uh parent or guardian
uh on this involved in an educational
organization of any kind whether it's
k through 12 higher education
you can be become a member and anyone
can also join silver state schools
credit union by making just a one-time
donation to pbs which as you know is
very very involved with uh
uh with the education community and so
that's just a one-time
40 donation and and you're in for life
with both us
and with pbs and so it's great for more
information from the silver state
schools credit union call 702-733-8820
or just visit their website
at silverstatecu.com las vegas right